I sleep with the jackhammer and the bulb right next to me because I thought I was supposed to.
I zap my wife a lot less luck to share.
Well, that actually makes like a little more fun.
So that's good.
So yeah, if you ask that question about putting it under the bed,
if you have the jackhammer, then you can put it under the bed.
I was going to ask if there was anything preventing one from snuggling with the hammer bulb,
connected to a jackhammer.
No, except that, you know, you are getting a higher amplification.
So you will end up with this problem that people are talking about to people today,
that you're going to produce more electromagnetic electricity.
So you're going to have a charge.
So electromagnetic.
So when you rub your feet against, you know, on the carpet and you touch somebody and you give them a shock,
it's because you have more electrons on the surface of your skin.
And it is the same thing with if you use the right, you can develop electrons on the surface of your skin.
So when somebody touches you, they get a shock.
If you're using the jackhammer, you have an amplification of that.
So you will actually produce more electrons, especially if the bulb is right next to you.
And you're using the jackhammer.
So some people don't like that.
So I understand I'm joking that it brings a little fun to your marriage, but it's not very pleasant.
So personally, I don't use the jackhammer because I've got used to snuggling with the bulb.
So that if I was, if that bothered me at the light bothered me and stuff,
I would just use the jackhammer to put the bulb underneath me while I slept.
And then that would solve that problem.
Now, what should I have seen is not to touch the jackhammer.
Not a problem as the frequency cheddar is better than the band.
So that's just, that's fun.
You really don't need to, if you have the jackhammer, you don't need to snuggle with the bulb.
So.